colombia ya tiene sus primeras vacunas
contra el hobbit 19 son 50 mil dosis del
fármaco de facer y variantes que
llegaron al aeropuerto eldorado en
bogotá como parte de una serie de
entregas de un total de 1 millón 650 mil
vacunas que se espera que arriben al
país en un plazo de tres semanas según
confirmó el gobierno colombiano esta
primera entrega de vacunas se da cinco
días antes del inicio previsto de la
campaña de vacunación el 20 de febrero
una fecha que se adelantaría a partir de
este primer lote de vacunas
el presidente colombiano iván duque
informó que el 70% de la población sería
vacunado antes de fin de año esa es la
meta que se ha trazado en el marco de
esta llamada campaña masiva de
vacunación la llegada también de las
vacunas se dan un marco de críticas al
gobierno por la lentitud que algunos le
atribuyen en la compra de las vacunas y
en la puesta en marcha de la vacunación
así como un fuerte contraste con otros
países de américa latina por ejemplo
chile que ya va por casi dos millones de
vacuna dos países vecinos como ecuador o
perú que se iniciaron sus campañas de
inmunización o incluso venezuela que
recibió cien mil dosis de la vacuna rusa
sputnik por todo esto crece la ansiedad
los ciudadanos para esta vacunación que
se espera sea la salida de la enfermedad
en un país que ya tiene más de 2
millones de contagiados y más de 57 mil
muertos